I had to transition
The company was just sold
So we had to move out of
Symantec into our own space
And went through a full RFB with different
Cloud providers as well
as data center providers
And came to a realization IBM Cloud and VMware
was the right solution for Veritas
IBM was the first one that
actually had the offering
Both on bare metal as well
as the VM stack and VM cloud
It was the only solution
that made sense
Nobody else offered the
spectrum of the options
I'm hybrid
But 95% in the cloud
I really wanted to
have a very seamless migration
To anywhere, because the
company was already live
The open architecture
that IBM Cloud provided
The bare metal that IBM Cloud
provided, it allowed me to
Both use our own product, Veritas product
and VMware tools to be
able to move live work load
With minimal to no impact to our business
On a Friday night go home
And by Monday morning they
come in and everything is working
They don't even know that I moved them
That was important
The big win for IT is
Not to interrupt the business
We moved 95% of our enterprise
applications into IBM Cloud
Both on the bare metal and VMware
and out of the thousand workloads running on IBM Cloud
Out of those, 80%, 90% of it is running on VMware
and the other 10% to 20% is running on bare metal servers
Even though I'm on the public cloudI have the security of a virtual private cloud
Being the Chief Security Officer
It enables me to have
a little bit more sleep
The bare metal is
being the key for me
But we have lots of applications
that have been there forever
Now the next journey is the
application modernization
To truly make them
cloud-aware and utilize
The services that is available to us